expérience diratil plus tard
entreud les progrès numériques pour plus
d'accessibilité Maria 59 ans vit à
Guille en cours nonvoyante cette femme a
développé un grand intérêt pour les
nouvelles technologies au service du
handicap détecteur de couleur machine à
lire ou thermomètre vocalisé au total
près d'une dizaine d'outils lui facilite
la vie au quotidien et permett de
limiter l'utilisation du brail c'est de
mieux en mieux parce que avant on avait
appareil qui lisait mais ça faisait
vraiment robotique que là on dirait
presque une voix humaine qui parle ce
boîtier électronique fixé sur une canne
classique se connecte au Bluetooth du
smartphone il délivre des informations
sonores dans son casque à conduction
osseuse c'est que ça nous détecte les
bah tous les obstacles et ça nous évite
de bah de foncer dedans avec la canne
que la canne les touche Maria est
quelqu'un de très curieuse qui qui a
envie en fait de de découvrir les choses
donc c'est vrai les à ce niveau-là les
les nouvelles technologies en fait lui
permet d'être le plus autonome possible
atteinte d'une rétinite pigmentaire la
quincagénire a commencé à perdre la vue
dès l'âge de 16 ans les innovations
numériques l'aident à mieux vivre son
handicap mais ne remplace pas son animal
jaika bon c'est c'est bien la canne pour
ceux qui veulent pas de Chin c'est très
bien mais le même trajet qu'on va faire
avec la canne en en 20 minutes avec le
chien on peut le faire en 5 10 minutes
parce que la canne on doit chercher la
porte on doit chercher les passages
piétau on doit chercher on doit chercher
tout ça que le chien on lui demande nous
direct à l'avenir Maria aimerait
acquérir des lunettes à intelligence
artificiel pour notamment reconnaître
les visages et lire les panneaux de
signalisation un appareil novateur mais
son coût de plusieurs milliers d'euros
est pour le moment un frein pour cette
technophile